chad's army says that the country's
president idris daby has
died just a day after he won elections
securing him a sixth term in office
troops have been deployed to the streets
of the capital unjamina
air and land borders are closed until
further notice and
a curfew is in place deebe was
reportedly killed as
he led his troops in a front-line battle
against rebels in the north of the
country
d.b son has been named as interim head
of state but the rebels
have rejected that transition and are
vowing to march
on the capitol
residents of chad reacted with this
belief to the televised announcement of
president idris debbie's
death
martial of chad idris as he did
every time when the republic's
institutions were seriously threatened
took the heroic lead in a combat
operation against terrorists
who had come from libya he was injured
in the engagement
and died after being brought back to
germany
the news came just hours after he was
declared the winner of the country's
presidential election on april 11th
it would have been the long-term
leader's sixth term in office
it's sad news the presidential election
took place calmly
and just a day after they announced his
win
they announced his death
this news is very surprising
on a human level it is touching
but there are rumors that the
information disseminated by the
transition council
is false
it is not known why debbie would have
visited the front line
or participated in the clashes the exact
circumstances of his death remain
unclear
and some observers questioned the
military's narrative
following the announcement a military
council deployed the army around the
capital
and imposed a curfew it also dissolved
the country's government and parliament
and named debbie's 38 year old son as
transitional leader
he heads the elite presidential guard
that oversaw his father's security
debbie was among the world's longest
serving leaders
the herder's son took the classic path
to power through the army
in 1990 his rebel forces overthrew the
then president in a coup
during his 30-year rule he became a key
ally of the west
and supplied weaponry and soldiers to
the anti-jihadist campaign in the sahar
region
his unexpected death could spell the
beginning of a new period of uncertainty
in a deeply troubled region
let's bring in reid brody here he's
counsel and
spokesperson for human rights watch and
joined us
from barcelona thanks for being with us
mr browdy first of all idris davie
ruled chad for more than three decades
how would you describe his legacy
well i would say charitably it's a mixed
legacy
um of course idris debbie uh
came to power by defeating his
predecessor hissen habre
who was uh probably the most certainly
the most brutal
of chad's leaders who committed crimes
against humanity and who was recently
convicted actually by a court
in senegal for massive crimes including
sexual slavery murder torture um
and idris debbie came in promising
chadian's liberty
and he established a truth commission
one of the first in africa
to look at the crimes of his predecessor
but it soon became
very clear that he was going to use the
same tactics and he brought back many of
hobray's people
and he became more and more autocratic i
mean he never reached that level of
brutality and and
he always maintained a semblance of of
constitutional rule there were elections
there were opposition parties there was
opposition press
but these elections more and more became
mere formalities
and there was human rights abuses
arbitrary detention and probably
most of all corruption during idris
debbie's time in power
oil was discovered in the south of chad
and began to flow
uh through uh through cameroon and and
but that oil money was used to to
support the elite of his country
okay what do you expect to happen in
chad
now with the death of its leader he'd
been in place for three decades as we
mentioned
what are the prospects for achieving
stability in chat at this point
well of course that's that's the thing
that chad
offered with stability i mean this is a
a very
volatile region you've got libya falling
apart above chad you've got
sudan which broke in half you've got a
war in central african republic you've
got
um uh boko haram in
in nigeria so what idris debbie offered
was stability
um and that's why for three decades
the west supported idris debbie just as
they had supported his and operate
before him
um i think now uh
we don't know i mean i'm very worried
today
uh for the situation in chad itself i
mean on
on the one hand the rebels i don't think
that will happen but the rebels could
win and and they could be worse than
debbie
uh many of them are tied to his harbor
they come from this small ethnic group
and they could start taking revenge
on uh on on idris debbie's ethnic group
um and also the other possibility
is that the government will take
advantage of this
um chaos as they did in 2008 when rebels
marched into gemina and were turned back
take advantage of this situation to
attack and disappear political opponents
so it's a very scary period right now
inside of chad
mr brady thank you very much for your
insights that was reid brody counsel and
spokesperson for human rights watch
you're welcome
you